and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to today's episode
today we're going to talk about feeling
stuck creatively feeling stuck
emotionally and what it takes to get
unstuck and we're gonna answer your
questions with today's guest rosy Golan
is here today one of my favorite
musicians and we're really grateful to
have you today your newest collection of
songs is called collecting bullets so
folks can definitely check that I will
be talking about some music today the
reason I wanted to call this one unstuck
or feeling unstuck because I read an
interview you were doing between albums
when you were recording collecting
bullets and and that that phrase
actually came out you said I was feeling
stuck and so we have some questions the
way this podcast typically works is we
we don't interview people per se we have
some conversations that there tend to be
based around questions that our audience
has but really we just inject ourselves
into the whole experience so I'm hoping
to talk to you about about that creative
process and and what got you unstuck and
what you had to go through in order to
get unstuck or our first question today
is from Sam in Cleveland Ohio since I
graduated from college I have been
working in College Admission I've been a
tour guide man loves working with
students and so that was always
something that I truly loved doing and I
did find purpose in when I was a student
and I kind of kept me going through
college
even though college wasn't quite my
thing now that I've graduated I've now
worked for four years in college
admission and sometimes I feel like that
gives me a true purpose but then there's
other times that I feel like it's not
how do you keep going when not every
single day feels like you're working
towards your true calling or purpose how
do you move forward or maybe should I
start looking for something else so this
is fascinating Rose I'm sure once you
became a musician all the drudgery was
gone and everyday you felt fully
fulfilled like you rode here
unicorn like on a rainbow road to the
studio right are there days where you
feel like like you supposed to be doing
there's years when I feel that way you
know what somebody once gave me some
really good advice when it came to
relationships and I kind of also use it
with music which is no one person can be
everything to you so like if you are you
know in a relationship that person can't
be your best friend and your lover and
your confidant and the person that you
go to for every single thing there are
things that you're not gonna want to
talk to them about or that you're not
gonna be able to laugh with them about
you're not always gonna share in every
single thing I mean you can get as close
to that as possible but the truth is
like there are things that I can get
from my girlfriends that I can't get
from a partner you know that I can get
from my mom that I can't get from my
girlfriends you know and so forth and I
think it's the same with what I do for a
living there are like literally months
on end where I'm just like what am I
even doing and the longer I've been
doing it the more I realized that in
order for me to like really appreciate
what I do and like also to like stay
re-energized in doing what I do is to
also do other things yeah that's the
thing is like to just realize and also I
you know because these days I don't
think most people are probably going to
do the one thing that they're doing for
the rest of their lives you know it's I
think that we like it's cyclical now I
think that you can have more than one
career in a lifetime yeah I think we're
seeing the the data bear out now where
you know what we have people who are
younger than us are gonna go through
more careers than our parents went
through job titles right so our parents
may have had the opportunity to work at
a factory for thirty years or whatever
not your parents apparently because
before the podcast you tell us that your
father was a national gypsy and I think
if we're focused on career we might be
focused on the wrong thing but I also
think
conversely if we're just focused on
passion
we might be focused on on the wrong
thing yeah Ryan and I often talk about
cultivating a passion and I think maybe
the thing that is missing here for Sam
or the thing that was missing for me and
Ryan and in our corporate lives of
yesteryear was we we forsook creativity
and I think the opposite can also bet
you're under I know a lot of creative
folks who forsake the getting the
creation out into the world because it
seems disingenuous so like I don't want
to seem marchetti or whatever like I get
it but it's what you're talking about
with the relationships there's a balance
there and I think there's a balance with
anything I think with Sam's career what
she's doing right now for her job I
guess the question I would ask her is
what can you do outside that job if you
could do anything and I think some of us
we tend to go toward the we without
knowing it we pacify ourselves like well
I'll just pop on YouTube for a few hours
I'm just gonna turn on some TV or I'm
gonna waste some time effectively and
that's not what I mean like what would
you do if you could do anything but but
if you had the opportunity what would
you really do what would you do that
serves the greater good and I think
Rosie you found that in music you you
what you've done with music has served
the greater good you've created
something beautiful several beautiful
bodies of work but in doing that I
imagine I imagine there was a lot of
heartache in the process of doing it
well I mean I think in general one thing
that songwriters often do and I try not
to is you kind of self-destruct a lot of
times to create which is a terrible
habit but it's one I've I think I've you
know I've grown out of because you have
to like you you have to find inspiration
within other places
yeah it's funny I was listening to yours
one of your songs earlier today don't
you dare and I don't I don't know what
that song is exactly about but one of
the lines is every once in a while I do
something that stirs me up yeah and I
think that's like kind of hits the nail
on the head with what you're trying to
say with creativity yeah I think the
only thing for Sam - she needs a reframe
kind
how she's approaching her her career
approaching her life like yeah she talks
about the true purpose or that that true
passion and or their true calling and
the good news is is like Sam there's not
just one true calling for you out there
there are many many different callings I
know for me I used to think that if I
found that one true calling then I would
get I'd ride to work on a rainbow road
riding a unicorn I'd wake up every
single day happy the problem with that
expectation is is that that's mania
that's manic if you're waking up every
single day super excited you're a manic
person and a man a person at its
terminus is a there naked directing
drugs yeah exactly in the middle of the
street so so instead of focusing on that
true calling instead of focusing on that
true purpose I would encourage Sam to
focus on living a meaningful life
and living a meaningful life is when our
short term actions align with our long
term values and our beliefs and when you
do that the beautiful byproduct of
living a meaningful life is is happiness
but expecting that one true calling to
wake up every single day and say oh man
like I'm I can't wait to go and enroll
students in the college I mean that's
that's never gonna happen even with Josh
and I I mean we still got to pay taxes
we got to go on tours or a lot of a lot
of drudgery that we have to work through
I'll tell you the one thing that keeps
me going though is knowing that what I
do it it's at least helping a few people
out and and that's really what I focus
on I don't really focus I'm like okay
how many millions of people can I help
or help you know how many likes can this
post get but it's like if I can do
something that's going to do something
for my community or you know somewhere
across the world like that's what really
keeps me going and I think Sam is doing
that right now she does have a job where
she is adding a little bit of value to
the community and and I'm not saying
that well Sam just focus on you know
adding value to the community and that's
going to that's going to be the answer
your question here but that will help
her at least feel good about what what
she's doing for her job it's like I
think about I saw this was like a meme
of this gentleman quoted he was from
Nigeria or something refugee and he got
a job at
Center and he was talking about how much
he loved his job he's like man I get to
talk to people in the community I get to
help people with their problems I and
and just coming at it from that aspect
he could feel good about the work he was
doing instead of you know I know when I
was in management and retail it was like
what am i doing I'm just like sitting
here and I'm taking phone calls selling
cell phones it was very easy for me to
get down but you know now I look back I
could have reframed that a little bit
differently although the vast majority
of that job did not align with my values
and beliefs that's where we get into the
problem and you as funny about the the
ECD was Nigerian who works at a call
center yeah him going in that job it's
amazing how two people two autonomous
human beings can go into the same
situation and say man I absolutely love
this and the person right next to them
who's doing the same tasks are saying I
absolutely hate this and part of it has
to do with like what's appropriate for
you but I think really a lot of it has
to do with reframing your perspective
yeah have you ever gone through
recording something in your life started
to hate the process because it wasn't
going well that's a type of feeling
stuck I think recording no but writing
yes I definitely have like actually
that's not true
I did I went through I probably went
through like a year of writing and
recording an EP and scrapping it and
it's the only time that I've ever done
that that I've ever spent my time and
effort and energy writing something
recording it and then never releasing it
and that was it felt like such a failure
but I think it's the same thing like
looking back if I had first of all been
like less precious about it because I
knew that you know putting new music out
would actually be really great and like
moving things forward and people were
waiting for new music and also if I had
reframed it in the sense of like okay
but like that was true in that moment
and like because that's the thing with
music like what's true and the in that
moment isn't going to be true in this
moment so like what I'm writing you know
it works for that part of my life and
that's what music really is like for
myself as a singer-songwriter like those
are snapshots of like those moments in
my life so for instance my first
record I'm so far away from that even
though that's the record that so many
people often go back to I could never
recreate that because I was in a
completely different phase anyway I had
to recreate it now would feel
disingenuous yes absolutely it would it
would you'd be referencing a person that
was no longer you you're like well yeah
I mean I guess we looked fairly similar
yeah but but I have the the compound
interest of years of wisdom that I've
gained since yeah it's crazy like I can
hear the experiences but if I listen
back to it I sound so different to
myself which is really weird but you
know what's fascinating is those songs
even today someone goes back and listens
to your first album they a lot of people
can relate to that because that's what
they're going through
currently right and so you have that
sort of time capsule of your life but
it's also and it's a time capsule by
proxy for other people's lives and and
I'm sure you get messages all the time
where people that really helped me get
through X whatever X is Sam I wanna send
you a copy of our book everything that
remains speaking of this is a book that
I wrote when I was 32 with with Ryan and
I couldn't go back and write that you
know six years later and and and say and
be completely different it would be a
totally different book for better or for
worse it's my favorite thing that we've
ever done but it's also it was like
people often asked how long did it take
to write that book I took thirty two
years right the first album is the same
way right it takes 22 or 25 years or
whatever the process is to get there
because it's the lived experience of
childhood and everything up to that and
so today I'm gonna send you copy that if
you like our if you liked our podcast
you're like the audiobook version of the
book but Ryan and I in there we also
talked about sort of walking away from
the corporate world not for the sake of
just walking away from the corporate
world but because our priorities we
didn't even know what our priorities
were and that was a bit of a problem for
us and once we reprioritize our lives we
realize like oh this doesn't align with
my values and so I was able to figure
that out and start walking not just
walking away from the corporate world
but walking towards something that was
more meaningful for us well to move on
to the rut lightning-round Ryan
all right our first question is from
Mary Ann to become unstuck I need a good
plan
I'd love some ideas on how to map out a
plan I have totally been there Mary Ann
all aspects from where to start to how
to document now Rosie what we do here is
so we try to answer these questions and
short shareable less than hundred forty
character responses we call them minimal
Maxim's but what we really do is we just
Mandar on a lot and we discuss it until
we come up with something that's pithy
enough for Jessica to share she also
puts all of these in the show notes and
over at minimal Maxim's com
we are at the minimalists on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram if you have a
question for us Rosie you're at Rosie go
on Twitter and Instagram yes all right
you can find her there all right so Mary
Ann wants to know about having a plan
Ryan my first thing I think it's most
important part to be coming unstuck is
you got to have a plan to get unstuck
see I disagree okay and and I think
here's my pithy answer well done packet
here you don't get unstuck with more
planning you get unstuck with less
friction and I think my aside there is I
think it a plan is useful once you are
unstuck but I think sometimes we stay
stuck somewhere because we're not
willing to take any any actual action we
just want to plan more around it
recording process or writing process it
for me writing is like well I'll just
keep writing and write and write if I
continue to write then I won't ever have
to publish this thing I don't know if
you've gone through that yeah I mean I
think sometimes planning makes you feel
like you've already done the thing yeah
yeah that's definitely a danger yeah so
I think like with getting stuck for me
probably planning would be the opposite
and just literally being like okay I'm
just gonna do this thing is probably the
thing that's always made me unstuck like
you know feeling super burnt out on New
York and just being like being like okay
I'm packing my bags I'm going to Paris
without like sitting down with me like
okay so I'm gonna save up this much or
I'm gonna wait this long or this is what
I'm gonna do and this is these are the
areas I'm gonna research I didn't do any
of that you know you made a decision I
made a decision I think I think that I
think if I were to capsule
that nathie answer for Rosie is decision
is the antidote to stuckness because you
you had to make a decision you know what
even if it's not the perfect decision
maybe it's even the wrong decision at
least that got you unstuck but then of
course having a plan once you are
unstuck I think is important and the
thing that brought up here about
friction is yet to get unstuck sometimes
you have to remove some of the friction
there there might be obstacles in your
way that are making you feel stuck for
you it might have been New York that's a
recipe because we always talk about how
adding friction to our lives is
necessary sometimes but in this case
you're saying take what friction is bad
mmm and it's like it's driving on a road
right where where if you have too much
friction it's just Boulder after Boulder
and the gravels two of you you're doing
off-roading with without a vehicle that
is an off-road vehicle it's too much
friction you can't traverse that
landscape conversely if it's all ice
then you're gonna slide all over the
place you don't have enough friction I
think you want to find what's the
appropriate amount of friction and I
think the creative process often allows
us to to sort of inject some good
friction into our life it's because I
took this question as not being stuck in
the creative process but being stuck in
life and when I look at you know my days
of yesteryear if I didn't have a plan
there's no way I would have been able to
leave my corporate job there's no way I
would have been able to be on this
journey with you with the minimalists I
mean when I found myself stuck well here
let me give you my short answer and then
I'll unpack it a little bit so in order
to have a good plan you must be clear on
three things your outcome why you want
that outcome and the massive action
steps needed to reach your desired
outcome so when I was working in the
corporate world I knew that I didn't
want to work there anymore but I
couldn't get up and quit right I mean if
anyone tells you to just quit and start
a blog head for the hills
that is the worst advice ever right so
for me to go from having copious amounts
of debt working 6070 sometimes 80 hours
a week in a job that I hated to getting
to breaking away from that the life that
I had built the last decade
that took a huge plan for me sure so for
me it was I wanted to leave my job that
was my outcome and then getting the
reasons why like why do I well I want to
create more I want to be able to reclaim
my time I want to be able to get out of
debt having having those reasons why is
what really gave me the leverage to take
these mashed massive action steps Mayo
those steps in good maybe the the level
of planning required is congruent to the
the size of the the step you're trying
to take I definitely get lost in the
details and yes if you're planning a
trip to Paris like in trying to plant
every little I mean we're I'm going to
Scotland in July and like trying to plan
you know our two weeks there is I get
overwhelmed and eventually I have a
really good friend Josh Wagner and he's
like hey man I'll take care of the
planning I'm like oh thank you so much
like we just show up he's like this is
what you owe me for the Airbnb this is
what you owe me for the ferry ticket so
so yes I totally agree that we can get
caught in the details of planning I
think that once we have a basic plan
though so going back to when I was in my
corporate job the plan was to get out of
debt what is step number one to getting
out of debt well I've got to stop
spending more money than what I make not
only that but I have to start to cut
back on you know certain luxuries or
non-essentials conveniences yeah I had
to cut back to start paying down as much
debt as I could so yes I I think that I
probably was stuck for five years
thinking that oh well here's here's
where I am here's where I need to be and
there's way too many steps in between
but coming up with just a few reasonable
massive action steps I want to say
massive action it's like picking up and
moving to Paris it's not just talking
about moving to Paris it's about you
know going to the gym and working out
it's not about just googling gyms near
me and then you call them and you sign
up like uh-oh sign up for the gym I'm
there like you have to actually go to
the gym so yeah there is a just like
with the friction there's a balance
between no friction and too much
friction exactly and there's a balance
between too much planning and no
planning at all
Dean all right our next question is from
NUI how do you resolve creativity blocks
well this is this is a fascinating one
and I don't know if you experienced this
Rosie with writer's block or oh no if
they're singer-songwriter block or
whatever I don't believe in it I don't
think it exists and and here's why there
are times where of course it's more
difficult and things aren't flowing and
like there's a flow state where
everything's just going right and you're
like no matter what I write down but
it's it's gold coming off my my feather
quill
it feels great there are those times but
I think it requires the actual drudgery
the those times where we consider it to
be writer's block and so my short answer
is writer's block a shorthand for this
is not a priority I think for a lot of
us were like yeah writings hard but so
is being a bricklayer and bricklayers
don't get bricklayers block ever right
but they're both creating something
meaningful
one person's creating a structure the
other person's creating something that
is more based in creativity like a book
or a song but I I think yes it exists
meaning the drudgery exists are the
times where you just want to put your
head through a wall on say should I even
be doing this but are sometimes you've
you've gone through were where you were
just stuck with the creativity block
well I think for me the thing that I
always try to remind myself was again a
thing that I've just like learned over
the years of writing which is that even
if you write the shittiest song today it
took that song to get to the next one
amen yeah so that's the thing it's like
you know I never I never ever say okay I
have writer's block so I'm just gonna
stop writing you thought you just have
to keep doing it anyway and even if it
sucks even if you like write the worst
song you just have to keep doing it so I
think that's it's true in that sense
like it's not like I'm not gonna go to
work just because like I'm having a bad
day you know like you still got to do it
anyway yeah you know that's I was just
gonna say so like that's kind of how I I
moved through
I don't just like stop you don't try to
get around it you you go through it as
opposed to trying to get around and
that's the thing is is going through it
all you can't experience the sort of the
the peak of the mountain top without
without traversing the valley right and
you're gonna have every creative process
has a valley and I think especially at
first there's this weird dichotomy
because most of what you do is bad when
you first start doing the thing when you
first start writing songs or start
writing books
the thing that you do you're not that
good at yeah you you haven't developed
the skill but then as you develop the
skill you you want to be able to to get
that out there in the world but you know
that it's not that good and so 80% of
the time you want to put your head
through a wall but over time that that
attenuates and it's 70 percent of the
time and eventually it's like half the
time even now half the town pretty good
writer I still want to put my head
through a wall the other half of the
time it is glorious and that's where the
payoff is the real payoff is after the
the sort of drudgery yeah it's funny I
just thought of a put the answer just
kind of tying in that the planning
question before this so when it comes to
creativity planning is not creativity
creativity is creativity and and that's
really where I think we do get stuck
into creativity to process it's like we
outline we research but we actually
don't get to the creativity of the thing
I tell my writing students research is
not writing right exactly so uh the the
other the other pet the answer I got
here is limitations breed creativity so
I know for me it's like if I were
working on a book right now and we have
these we have these timelines they're
they're kind of rough but Josh Sean and
I we'd be meeting for like less three
weeks last month on Mondays and we
talked about what we need to do to get
this book this book moving and I have a
week to do certain things and like I got
to get them done so I get them done
we've known about the book for months
haven't got really anything done but but
having this limitation that I've imposed
on myself or that we've opposed on it it
really forces me to sit in the chair and
be creative
who is it as a Hemingway he was like I
think it was Fitzgerald I think he I
actually I tribute this quote the
podcast
because so many people said this but lay
aside I write only when I'm inspired but
I make sure I'm inspired every morning
at 8:30 a.m. right and I think that
that's the that's true you have to put
yourself in the chair the best four
words I've ever been taught about
writing is sit in the chair and you have
to do that regularly like you know I
think that's the thing it's like oh well
how do I fix this
get creative with it yeah yeah and
sometimes those limitations they force
you to be more creative cuz you if you
have abundant unlimited resources that's
a different kind of stuck it's an
infinite landscape it's the paradox of
choice and we also don't want to be
there so add some limitations to breed
that creativity
looks like we have we have several more
surprise questions this week about shame
about advice for feeling stuck in your
career about leaving your job to
experience the world Rose Eve
experienced the world more than just
about anyone I know we can definitely
talk about that and I want to talk to to
Rosie about taking time to sort of
breathe between creative projects which
I know that you've done and also you
bought a house recently in Nashville and
I want to talk about before the podcast
we were talking about yeah the the
stress of filling the space so you're
welcome to us ask us some questions as
well Ryan I have about 12 answers I
can't promise it'll right answer but we
do have some answers to you are for you
and if you want to hear all that you can
listen to this week's maximal episode
available exclusively on patreon that's
right you're currently listening to our
weekly minimal episode but each week
Ryan and I record an entirely different
long-form maximal episode on the
minimalist private podcast which gives
us the private space we need to talk
about topics we don't typically talk
about in public plus patreon is the best
way for us to fund this podcast and keep
it a hundred percent advertisement free
when you subscribe to the minimalist
private podcast on patreon you'll
receive a personal link so that our
maximal episodes play in your favorite
podcast app you also get access to our
entire back catalogue of more than 100
private podcast episodes find all the
details and all the good stuff including
an additional podcast episode every week
over at the minimalists comm slash
support Ryan what else you got for us
this week
as
I just want to encourage people to read
more and get informed and now here are
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners this is Julie from
southern Minnesota so I recently heard
about a survey done in Canada in the US
on the John Tesh radio show saying that
we spend more hours a week on the toilet
than we do exercising so kudos to you
Josh and Ryan for again opening my eyes
to possibilities on how to squeeze in
some exercise and having that gentlemen
on your show I learned a lot today thank
you and I just like I said I just wanted
to share that we spend more time on the
toilet which was on average three hours
a week than we do exercising how sad is
that
hi Josh and Ryan MD from Meridian Idaho
and with Mother's Day quickly
approaching I wanted to share a
meaningful gift giving idea when my
children were young and didn't have much
money I answer their mom what do you
want for Mother's Day question with a
poem a song or a prayer I love receiving
these creative efforts my children are
now 21 20 and 16 and I still received
some variation of this standing differ
quest and to keep it clutter free but
just as meaningful I scan their
creations into my computer and throw
away the paper copies in CD all right
Joe that's almost it for this episode
thanks again to rosy Golan for joining
us today make sure you check out her
latest project it's called collecting
bullets and real quick for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalists I
teach an online writing class so if you
want to learn how to write better you
can head on over to how to write better
or give a teaching this class now for
what's it been Ryan maybe 11 for sure
yeah so so nine eight years almost eight
years and what I've learned is that the
rising tide lifts all boats with respect
to writing I first started teaching this
people who wanted to write blogs but
then people want the right books I had
written several books like your books
really resonate with me other people
wanted to improve their emails so
improving business emails which was odd
to me I when I had a first few people
show up like oh okay I can help you out
with that when I realized like improving
your writing learning how to write
better improve your writing across all
platforms including text messages so if
you want to learn to write your first
book or your best text messages Reineke
demas the author of the best-selling
text message it's how to write better or
gets an online writing class you can
check it out
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast leave us
a voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or send a voice
memo to podcast at the minimalists comm
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists and if
you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list at the
minimalists comm you'll also receive our
a simple Sunday
emails each week for our added value
this week I'm gonna play you out with my
favorite Rosi Golan's song it's called
think of me from her first album it's
called The Drifter in the gypsy and if
you leave here today with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listen y'all
we'll see you next time and minimus